he had to leave the house  you're still really young but your peers  are about to see it mainly my best  friends and what they think about it  probably  who cares about everyone else this time  you don't like it I'm probably gonna  keep it quinnyn wants it though too huh  just give me a dirty look what would be  something you had to take with you I  would probably want to set up a  satellite there and you know get my NBA  channels on it was a very violent film  for sure I mean you smash ear mugs over  guys faces and things are bound to  happen I have no idea Isla yeah oh  that's right yes she told me that but I  forgot was there anyone in particular  that you're like I'm a little awestruck  here as soon as a young woman by the  name of Meryl Streep walked on to set  she's just a Marvel